in November 2015 and bang & olufsen
turned 90 years old and to celebrate
they created this the Bayeux lab 90 the
bail up nine looks crazy and underneath
all of this is over a hundred and twenty
pounds of an aluminum frame and then in
addition to that there are all the other
components including feet teen drivers
encompassing a full 360 degree range
around the unit all in all each speaker
weighs 275 pounds each driver also has
its own amplifier which means this thing
can put out 8200 watts of power and oh
yeah did I mention you'll want two of
them what really makes the bail AB 90s
stand out is that 360 design that means
that if you have a pair on either side
of your TV or set up in your living room
you can use their dedicated app to fine
tune the sound so you don't have to sit
in a specific spot and you can have the
right sound for watching a movie or
throwing a party
we got a brief demo and the sound is
incredible you can hear every little
foot tap and the brushes on the drums
and a jazz track and during a movie
dialogue is clear and crisp there's
almost no processing with deep here
everything's down to natural and ambient
almost like you're at a live performance
but if this is an amazing speaker it
comes with an amazing price tag the bail
lab 90s thirty eight thousand nine
hundred and ninety five dollars per unit
which means a pair will set you back
seventy nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety dollars the bail lab 90 was in
development for over two and a half
years and customers will start getting
the final hardware at the end of January
with a further software update coming in
July